the libs are coming for your parental
rights this viral clip care of our
friends at Libs of Tik Tok let's talk
about parental rights for a second
because it's become evident that it's
being used currently in this fight
against queer people and especially
queer kids who need more protections
than ever before like in catron and in
the US parental rights are being used to
thwart any rights of autonomy that the
kid might have and I'm sorry but kidss
do have autonomy we've already
established this for example if a kid
needs a blood transfusion and the
parents don't want to it's not the
parents right to refuse that blood
transfusion for that kid because it is
life-saving in the same respect if a kid
only needs to like use a different name
and pronoun in school there might be a
reason and a good reason they're not
coming out at home and they need a safe
place to be themselves and so to hell
with this idea of parental rights when
it comes to kids who have their own
consent and then their own bodily
autonomy and their own autonomy to their
personhood that need to be protected to
hell with this idea of parental rights
Libs 2024 to hell with parental rights
now you might say who cares this is just
some random weirdo and that's true but
we see the same belief articulated by
more prominent less random weirdos here
is aoc's take on the gop's parents Bill
of Rights proposal they are ask asking
the Republican party to keep culture
wars out of classrooms our children need
urgent and aggressive educational
Solutions the American Library
Association coming out against this
Republican
proposal when we talk about Progressive
values I can say what my Progressive
value is and that is freedom over
fascism okay but it's AOC you might say
everyone knows AOC Is On The Fringe yeah
sure maybe but then here again we have
an even less Fringe even less random
even more prominent weirdo saying the
same thing Rebecca put a teacher's Creed
into words when she said there's no such
thing as someone else's child no such
thing as someone else's child our
nation's children are all our
children no such thing as someone
meaning there's no such thing as your
child they're all my child me Joe Biden
the libs are coming out in full force
against parental rights they view the
family as the final impediment to their
agenda on the bright side this is the
best line of attack that the GOP
currently has parental rights is exactly
what gave Republicans Virginia it's
exactly one of the reasons that Ronda
santis has been so popular in Florida
the libs know that dismantling the
family is unpopular but they also know
that they've got to do it to seal their
power and the scary thing is despite the
unpopularity they've already been pretty
successful at doing just that right now
go to hall.com NES there is no better
time to build a daily habit of prayer
and meditation building a habit of
prayer can help you cultivate an
attitude of gratitude focusing on what
you are thankful for can increase
positive emotions and improve overall
well-being also you owe prayer to the
Lord your God so you need to pray hallo
is the number one Christian Prayer app
in the United States it has helped
countless people maintain a daily prayer
routine and it can help you too download
the app for free at hall.com you can set
prayer reminders and track your progress
all along the way not sure where to
start check out father Mike schmitz's
Bible in Year my favorite podcast
available on the hallo app for brief
daily readings and Reflections or pray
alongside Mark Wahlberg Jim cisel and
even some worldclass athletes with
hallow you can customize a personal
prayer plan that works for you listen
wherever you are with downloadable
offline sessions using hallow to connect
with others who share your beliefs and
values can provide a sense of belonging
support and Foster a sense of community
and you will learn to be a better person
in today's broken world right now go to
hall.com try three months for free
hall.com
slns we've got an update in the
congressman Jamal Bowman case your
Congressman Jamal
Bowman is is the man who is a Democrat
from New York and he pulled a fire alarm
to stop the house from voting on a
continuing resolution and then he lied
about it and he said oh no I was just
trying to open the door the signs were
really confusing and I just didn't I
didn't know so this excuse fell apart
pretty quickly when we saw the alleged
signs there's one that says emergency
exit only it says emergency exit only
push until alarm sounds door will unlock
in three 30 seconds yeah and so but it
says alarm will sound emergency exit
only don't go out this way uh so unless
Congressman Jamal is completely
illiterate uh it's not convincing that
he would have not known what these signs
meant but then what's weird is in the
picture we have camera footage of him
pulling the alarm he's he's not standing
in front of those signs the signs are
nowhere really to be seen in that
picture apparently it's because he
knocked the science down and then he's
not pushing on the door he's just
pulling the fire alarm on the wall so he
he couldn't even pretend as though he he
thought it was just a way to get through
the door he He Turned and pulled the
fire alarm there further more the way
that you know his excuses complete BS is
because he didn't even go out those
doors Congressman Jamal apparently uh
ran out through a different door on a
different floor because he didn't want
to get caught because he didn't realize
that they had cameras in the US capital
tells you a lot about the caliber of
democrat Congressman so this this
totally fell apart and now what are the
Republicans going to
do if the GOP does not vote to expel
this man from Congress this man who who
did a much more egregious Insurrection
than anything committed by the hornh
Haack guy or the midwestern Granny's or
the Lecter fell from Florida smiling for
the camera Congressman Jamal
Bowman if any of those guys are guilty
of insurrection Bowman is guilty of it
20 times over if the G does not expel
him from Congress GOP is in charge of
the house right now then the GOP is just
completely impotent it's just completely
pathetic Bowman for his part is now in
damage control mode so he he sent out
this messaging according to Politico
which blamed everything on the Nazi
Republicans and he said we we've got to
we've got to stop these Nazi Republicans
from trying to make a big deal over my
pulling the fire alarm and obstructing
an official Congressional proceeding
when Politico reported on the Nazi memo
a congressman Bowman then
backtracked and he he denied having sent
out the guidance he said I just became
aware that in our messaging guidance
there was inappropriate use of the term
Nazi without my consent without my
consent I condemn the use of the term
Nazi out of its precise definition it is
important to specify the term Nazi
refers to members of the Nazi party and
neo-nazis which would be a lot more
convincing if Congressman Jamal Bowman
had not called me a Nazi on Twitter back
in March so back in
March after I gave my CPAC speech where
I said boys and girls are different you
know and Congressman Jamal tweets out
and says Michael this is a direct quote
Michael nolles is a Nazi hellbent on
keeping only white men alive and in
power and then he went went on and on
and on so here Bowman insinuates I would
never use the term Nazi if I weren't
referring to German soldiers from the
1940s this was this happened without my
consent I completely disavow this I
would never do such a thing it's
terribly offensive oh yeah well was it
also accidental and non-consensual when
you called me a Nazi on Twitter the
tweet's still up was that still an
accident back in
March I don't know that I believe that
are you going to disavow that
Congressman Bowman are you going to
apologize to me are you going to
apologize to everyone for that that
awful decision no doubt made by some
low-level staffer to call me a Nazi for
saying
the he just keeps digging this is a guy
who is not thinking strategically and
this is one of the reasons also not to
lie it's bad to lie because lying is a
sin and can condemn your soul to hell
and you shouldn't do it for that reason
because it offends God
uh but another reason even if you don't
believe in God and you don't care about
your soul and if you're just in politics
another reason not to lie is you're
going to get caught it's very especially
when you're lying publicly to the media
in the age of Twitter where there's a
tweet for everything you're going to get
caught man especially if you're not
necessarily the sharpest tool in the
shed when you're not maybe the
most uh highlevel makavelli metni kind
of political strategist out there and
then you start spinning all these lies
and denying and backtracking and you're
going to get caught and so probably what
would serve Congressman Bowman is for
him to stop speaking immediately two
days ago probably uh but but this is a
real crime it's it's not it's not just
that he called me a Nazi or he called
Republicans Nazis and he's lying about
it and that's a little bit of a
political
Scandal obstructing an official
Congressional proceeding after the
Democrats have spent the last two years
whining and crying and screaming about
how January 6th was basically you know
the shots fired on Fort Sumpter I don't
you know give me a
break this guy if the GOP does nothing
here if the GOP doesn't seize on this
advantage and expel this Looney Tune
from Congress then what do we have the
GOP in Congress for boy what a great
clip that was now make sure that you
ring that Bell subscribe to the Michael
NS YouTube channel see you next time